Wow go there
so how's it
guys it's a new look
this is a story about Saudi people not
Saudi politics so this is Mosin Mosin
lived in the US for 12 years 20 years
yeah and you're back inside you've been
here two weeks yeah actually two months
oh yeah it's Rihanna okay too much for
total so today today with Muzzin he's
gonna take us to some cool places some
very interesting places he said tonight
there's even like a music event or
something yeah yeah at the boulevard we
are going to have some coffee at
Starbucks so this is a diplomatic zone
you're saying yeah is that why there are
a lot of trees and security this is
where all the embassies are basically
[Music]
it's a super hard place to understand
it's a very complex place yeah and there
are many layers Saudis always been
looked at as like the most conservative
country of it say from the outside right
yeah and so when I come here and I see
woman without head scarves some of them
or you know couples out nope and hanging
out when they're not married it's
definitely like it smashes a lot of
preconceptions I would say yeah it's
working done using it's super confusing
and hard to understand sorry I was out
of Starbucks yesterday in the road like
the genders were separated next thing we
get mixing journey you can see around
you live in Panama you grew up in Saudi
and you're Lebanese what did you call
that a third Wow so how's it how's it
feel to be back in Saudi
different yeah cool right on what's your
name I'm sorry
Green Peter yeah you're great
Starbucks is closed or a prior time Stu
do we do prayer in the Starbucks or now
no we don't okay this bitna close sure
it's like a break for America use this
is tradition
which already territory
this is our first stop for today we're
gonna go you're gonna get me what is
this called a fob though yeah we're
gonna get you I need I need to style how
is it possible that things change so
quickly so for example those woman we
were just talking to which I didn't get
on camera
it is a bit of a challenge actually to
get people on camera but they were
saying that a year ago they had to be
fully covered and now they're walking
around without any cover like how does
it change so quickly and they're no big
problems and it seems like there would
be big problems and like such a rapid
change I would think I also think that
the the society is ready for such
changes so it used to be there are
certain authorities within Saudi Arabia
that are not allowing for that change to
hang and these authorities are gone
their religious beliefs is not allowed
in most places in Saudi Arabia right now
not just this area anybody year or two
ago they were allowed they were
everywhere before yeah two years ago
they were everywhere they had the power
to
ask women to cover up now this is Olga
you can wear whatever you like this is
the new some pieces then you Saudi
Arabia really literally 50% of the
population under the age of 25 65
percent of the population under the age
of 30 so you'll have a huge amount of
youth in this in this country right and
this is a good news to any country as
long as they know how to utilize it and
generate a great society and a great
economy out of this really young power
it can have bad consequences this energy
is not channeled right the change in
Saudi Arabia will be faced with the
resistance from part of the population
that's that's absolutely true
but I would assume and I will say from
my or from what I witness that the
majority of Saudis are in favor of the
exchanges well said ma'am thank you for
I think it's interesting I think it's
it's gonna be interesting for you for
sure coming back ten years out of it and
then into it
it's definitely interesting for me
because I don't know what what okay
what's seen from the outside about Saudi
honestly is beheadings is flashes is so
yeah is the political narrative are the
political narratives but there's no
there's very little online about like
what life is like on the ground and this
is one story I'm showing one aspect and
my perspective as a traveler and I
understand that's not by any stretch any
full story the problem is though I can't
I can't talk to very conservative Saudi
you know what I mean I can't talk to the
woman they're just very conservative
that's just not gonna work right so I do
like by default only show the younger
more progressive woman are gonna be the
ones that are gonna talk to me or
definitely talking from well your trip
is still young you don't know who you're
gonna meet
thank you brother
as you can see
I want like a white white like a white
and a silk one like you're sort of like
okay let's try something else it's like
the the chicken ass version it's my
first though
dobe underwear we're trying to teach him
how to wear do you like it
time you look the same you have the same
one guys
it's a new look and I'm gonna walk this
through outside well actually this is a
very comfortable
[Music]
is it time let's die in that dude he
said your head was one of the biggest
head to they ever had
now when you wear it every day it will
stretch doesn't have a big it has
what does I like it like this so the
process of buying a coat doesn't just
stop at the store you actually you get
irons somewhere else
[Music]
anywhere in the world
hi it's like well Amanda
[Music]
he's call me a Palestinian he's asking
what was your nationality American Rick
Sanford let's go Vienna on iCarly yeah
yeah Beeman air Beeman
promise Egypt
that's soda soda yeah why are you sad
I'm Paxton Pakistanis Egyptian Bengali
Indian Syria Syrian mannequin duplicator
- usually many got really super diverse
here like every nationality in the
region is working here in Saudi some
Salam people we met yeah are from
diverse backgrounds right one of them
was amazed he was like it's the first
time I actually see an American yeah
the Middle East is usually put over
under one label and it's usually thought
to be this anti-american anti-western
hobbit yes there are those elements like
they exist for sure but the vast
majority through all my experiences in
the Middle East people are like that
yeah you know they're cool you're like
you're from the states cool it's like a
novelty because not too many Yanks are
walking down the street
that's not usually the choice of
vacation they they make so I think
there's probably a novelty to it but
it's also like it's not this
anti-american sentiment that you see all
the other news right where were you
saying that's instead a 911 to 999 as
emergency yeah so the cop cars are the
same as us cars yeah
motion please tell us what's going on
here this is the coordinates for this is
a co-working space as you might see this
is an environment young Saudis come to
it and create their startup yeah yeah
and this is just horrible space sir do
you net where are you work more buzzing
oh snap don't worry about it it's like
it doesn't exist all right where do you
want to go what city
Mayo Clinic yeah where's Table one
Arizona tears of joy assertion there's
two spots Minnesota Minnesota I've
gotten a lot of people have been
studying abroad since a long time
but now more people are focusing on
going to the US
okay interesting pictures how do you
like it feel super it's it's full yeah
why do I look more local than needed
just try to keep this on my head but
what I'm saying it's like I'm fresh off
the boat yeah just got here
and I can see well first of all it's
impossible to understand what this place
is like by going online you have no idea
sure that's true for everywhere but more
so for here because there's no content
yes very little Connor than on the
country in like these stars there are
very - very cool woman in there that
spoke perfect English that were very
driven and interesting it couldn't be on
camera so sort of the story here
a lot of woman for cultural reasons or
reasons of not wanting to be seen on
camera just can't be on camera this
woman and her friend their being to
drive tomorrow morning who's gonna do
that video on driving with a Saudi woman
not happening why you tell me man
everyone seems into the idea but then
when they sit on it a little bit they
decide not to but then they think about
it and then like I don't want to be
online driving
there's something in them yeah it just
look you know the concept of you know
being on a video online is just new to a
lot of them it's nail it yeah it's a new
to me this country is hungry for
entertainment yeah look at this crowded
streets
[Music]
the floors that is my entertainment
before but not like at this large-scale
right there were no horror shows like
we're seeing up here I have never seen
something like this before it's a really
new experience for the whole public here
that you know there's more fun things to
do
we got a fish tank of a coffee shop is
that a coffee shop
Wow very posh bro I gotta say it's a
good positive no I like super lot of
smiles a lot of friendly people like
these guys and it's actually a good way
for people to mix you know people to mix
yeah
what do you mean uh you know whatever
you see so guys hope you like that David
Moses and and hope you got something out
of that like I did there was a lot of
stimulation a lot of nice no you should
all come here and that was quite vice
you